well brian with gyms and restaurants and
other businesses cutting capacity now to
25 percent
city and county agencies are working
with osha to make sure these businesses
are complying with these new
restrictions
joe mohler is live from the strip with
more on enforcement joe
yeah well enforcement for these new
restrictions will be similar to what
we're already experiencing that we have
been throughout the pandemic with
cities and counties doing inspections
now business owners say they'll be doing
what they can to comply with these
restrictions so that they can keep their
doors open
we've required masks the entire time
they're in the facility
the new mass mandate won't change
business for nelson tressler at flipping
out extreme in the southwest valley
we're probably down
70 percent from our normal time it is
the capacity restrictions that will take
a toll on business
this restriction is going to further
limit us from
being able to have people in the
facility business owners like tressler
will work to comply with new
restrictions that start tuesday
including cutting capacity to 25 percent
businesses that don't follow can face
fines we do need posters up
and we have examples of that on our
website for capacity
now that we're dealing with reduced
capacity limitations
those posters will come in handy because
that needs to be posted on the daily
nevada kovid 19 mitigation call monday
terry reynolds from the department of
business and industry said counties and
cities
have been working with osha to inspect
businesses to make sure they are
complying
we mostly work with their referrals or
referrals
that we get for employees for business
so
in the background the counties and the
cities are really
doing their business inspections to date
roughly 10 000 complaints have been
observed osha found nearly 90 percent of
them were in compliance
the worst compliance rates have been at
water parks government buildings as well
as hotels and casinos
restaurants have had a 93 percent
compliance tressler says businesses will
be working hard to comply with
our hope is to survive and i think
that's a lot of business owners in las
vegas is we just
are trying to survive and get through
this
employees and customers are the ones who
filed the complaints on the osha website
and according to osha the zip code with
the most complaints is 89108 which
includes the strip
reporting live on the strip joe mohler 8
news now